so to end we have a Reddit story they
ask us for advice so us out of the out
of the kindness of her heart she says I
think I want to leave my marriage but I
don't know if what I'm feeling is real
or if I would be making a huge mistake
how can I be sure I'm doing the right
thing if I do decide to leave what can I
do to make it easier on my husband I
think I want to leave my husband of 26
years but don't know if I'm making a
mistake or how to go about doing it I 48
female have been married to my husband 5
or male for 26 years together for 28 we
have two kids 22 and 8 I absolutely
adore my kids they're amazing for a few
years now I have felt that I'm not happy
in the marriage and would prefer to be
on my own there is no one else involved
and I have no desire to meet anyone new
I was relatively Young when we got
married and had our first child my
husband is a nice man and hasn't done
anything bad or wrong but I have felt it
for years that he's not the one who I
want to be with and it's not his fault
he doesn't give me what I feel like I
need from a relationship I feel he
doesn't emotionally support me doesn't
understand me is it interested in me
doesn't listen to me doesn't spend time
with me doesn't have any Drive Etc
everything we do together is instigated
arranged and planned by me holidays days
out meeting friends birthdays Christmas
all he does is pay for it he spends most
of his time on his iPad or computer he
doesn't entertain me I want to be
happy
I think this is she's obviously got to
go this is a terrible life this
is oh my gosh they think I make this up
when I say women leave for no reason
they think I make this
up oh my
gosh I I'm actually speechless to be
honest okay first thing she says uh
she's she's trying to go down the victim
route of We Were Young when we had kids
okay so she's what 22-year-old she was
she's 48 so she had kids at 26 not young
so that's out the window um she says
that he doesn't do anything wrong and
you know I don't want it to affect him
so she loves him otherwise she wouldn't
really care about his feelings um and
obviously you're going to care about
someone after being with them for all
that time they've got two kids together
look the main issue I have here there's
two main issues the first one is I have
no desire to be with anyone else
uh otherwise what do you mean
by I want to be happy Define What
happiness looks like second problem I
have I want to be happy um I my biggest
problem was all he does is pay for it
yeah yeah that's like really I mean you
have to work to pay for it and and why
is it that hard to make like I
understand women want the men to make
plans but like is it really the end of
the world it's that whole thing of
emotional support again isn't it it's
the women have this idea that men are
going to be able to provide them the
emotional support that women can Prov
provide but you need to understand men
aren't built like that men generally
aren't good at emotional support they're
not good with emotional things well and
how many emotions can they keep up with
exactly I mean this chick just said he
did nothing wrong he does this man
imagine she's blatantly said nothing
wrong yeah imagine this guy's just like
living his life he's like I have a great
wife for 26 years two kids life is good
yeah he's thinking everything's fine
he's like I bet she doesn't work I bet
that that she's she's just sat at home
on social media seeing the Instagram
lifestyle and this is all just spewing
and she feels entitled to holidays days
out meeting friends birthdays I'm like
do you realize what our ancestors lived
through to get us here he does it what
is he an Entertainer or did you want to
go to a show he's supposed to entertain
you all the time entertain me I think
what we're seeing here is a very bored
woman we're seeing a very bored
housewife who who doesn't so should she
leave absolutely not go get a hobby go
join join a group start going to the gym
do something that's going to occupy your
mind um hey maybe you know women love to
talk about their problems go to therapy
sit and talk to a therapist oh no
that'll make them worse you reckon I
mean if she's sitting speaking to a
therapist at least she's not giving her
husband maybe maybe a guy therapist oh I
I don't think women should be going to
women therapists anyway I just make you
crazy this um so Lilith and Eve says
leaving my marriage is the best thing
I've ever done for myself and my mental
health and the best thing I've ever done
for my relationship with my son your
kids may be hurt and sad but they'll see
their mom be her own person and take
charge of her own life they'll have a
mom who cares about herself so much
she's willing to do one of the hardest
things there is to do can we highlight
that your kids may be hurt and sad who
this is like if I had to put this
comment as one thing it's called f them
kids yeah that's like basically this
comment is yeah F them kids awful woman
yeah they have them mom who cares about
herself so much she's willing to do one
of the hardest things there is to but
it's back to it's back to the selfish I
really think more than more than
anything the biggest cancer in society
is like gy centrism and and narcissism I
think we just have like female
narcissists everywhere well I think that
says it all doesn't it they'll have a
mom who cares about herself so much okay
so that's that's you you think kids
value that you think kids value a
selfish mother it's just oh my God I
can't understand it also it's just it's
just incorrect that the easiest thing to
do is to leave so how would anyone value
the easiest thing to do we value the
things that are hard to do in life and
it's hard to stick around a 30y year 40
50 year marriage is bloody hard that's
why we see it and value it so much so
actually you've done the easiest laziest
thing and then want to be rewarded
that's why it's like we we celebrate
single moms fat chicks and it's
like yeah women just love doing the easy
thing men never do that they never
celebrate the easy thing no they never
do no um but you know maybe I'm just
crazy and a big Doomer as usual yeah big
Doomer super
mean right do you get misogyny do you
get like the hatred vibes from me that's
what I keep getting on the internet I
just hate all women hat yeah hater she
absolutely hatred hatred Every Woman
every woman I meet is just
ah okay guys U make sure you like the
video let's get this video to 2,000
likes that's the most important metric
make sure you go subscribe to
Christine's Channel tell them a little
out my my YouTube channel um Christine
Grace Smith you can find me on Instagram
YouTube uh on Twitter as well and yeah I
basically look at the the state of
society and I try and present present
the side to things that isn't often
shown in the media so uh what I see is
common sense but common sense is no
longer very common in the world so I'm
trying to I'm trying to keep it going
for people I'm trying to keep common
sense a thing I'm trying to keep it
common but hey you'll only know if you
go check it out so I'll see you over
there all right guys like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and I'll talk to you next
time